let me ask for some dating advice from
jordan peterson how do you find
on that topic the love of your life
that's a good question
i was asked that multiple times
on my tour three times in a row in fact
because we asked people to use this
slido gadget
that's a popular question two very it
always came up to the top and i got
asked that three times in a row and i
didn't have a good answer and then i
thought
why don't i have a good answer
i thought oh i know why because that's a
stupid question
so so why yeah why
because it's it's putting the cart
before the horse here's the right
question
how do i make myself into the perfect
date
you answer that question and you will
not have any problem answering the
previous question it's like
what i want in a partner
if i offered everything i could to a
partner who would i be
you work on that ask that question just
ask just ask yourself okay
i have to be
the person that women
would want
okay what do they want
clean
that's not a bad start
reasonably good physical shape
so healthy
productive
generous
honest
willing to delay gratification so you
dance with a woman it's like what's she
doing what are you two doing well it's a
pattern you're there's patterns
happening around you that's the music
patterns patterns of being that's the
music
now can you align yourself with the
patterns of being gracefully that's what
she's checking out
and
then can you do that with her
and then can you do that in a playful
and attentive manner
and keep your bloody hands to yourself
for at least a minute
and so
can you dance in a playful manner it's
like you can go through this in your
imagination and you know you'll know you
know
and then you think well how far am i
from those things and the answer is
usually man it's pretty
horrible abyss separating you from that
ideal
but
the harder you work on
offering other people what they need and
want
the more people will line up to play
with you
so it's the wrong question it's like how
can i be the best partner possible
and then you think well if i do that
people will just take advantage of me
and that's the non-naive
objection
right because the naive person's saying
well i'll be good and everyone will
treat me right it's like
the cynic says no i'll be good and
someone will
take me out
and then you think well what
do you do about that objection and the
answer is well
you factor that in and that's why you're
supposed to be
what is it
as soft as a dove and as wise as a
serpent it's like i know you're full of
snakes
i know it
maybe i know it more than you do
but we'll play anyways
and that's the risk
that's right voluntarily right it's like
and what's so cool about that is that
even though the person you're dealing
with is full of snakes
if you offer your hand in trust and it's
real
you will evoke the best in them yeah and
that's true even i've dealt with people
who were
pretty damn
criminal
and pretty psychopathic
and sometimes dangerously so
and you tread very lightly when you're
dealing with someone like that
especially if they're intoxicated
and
even then
your best bet is
that
alert trust
it's the it's the only fact the only
thing i know that
if i had one client who is a paranoid he
was paranoid psychopath that's a bad
combination
he was a bad guy man he had like four
restraining orders
on him and restraining orders don't work
on the sort of people that you put
restraining orders on
and he used to be harassed now and then
by you know a bureaucrat in a bank with
with delusions of power and he would say
to them he he used to kind of act this
out to me when i was talking to him he'd
say
i'm going to be your worst nightmare
and he meant it
yeah and he would do it he had this
obsessional
psychopathic vengeance that was just
like right there
paranoid to the hilt and paranoid people
are hyper acute
so they're watching you for any sign of
deceit or manipulation and they're
really good at it because like they're
100 percent that's what paranoia is it's
100 focus on that
and
even under those circumstances if you
step carefully enough
you can
maybe
you can avoid the acts that's a good
thing to know if you ever meet someone
truly dangerous
absolutely i believe in that that
being fragile nevertheless taking that
leap of trust towards another person
even when they're dangerous especially
when they're dangerous
if you care
if there's something there in those
hills you want to find
then
that's probably the only way you're
going to find it is taking that risk
you